new technological developments are
bringing the vision of accident-free
Transportation closer and closer even in
large commercial vehicles electronic
assistance systems are constantly being
improved and extended into new areas and
new functions on the grounds of Berlin's
sugar-filled Airport
Mercedes demonstrates the current state
of the technology for utility vehicles
like buses and trucks
banheart the head of Daimler Trucks
division says that trucks turning
corners in the city still cause serious
accidents especially with cyclists the
drivers don't see in their blind spots
Daimler has now developed a sensor
system that recognizes bike riders warns
the driver and applies the brakes if the
driver doesn't react no one in the city
would want to experience these driving
maneuvers by an articulated bus but new
materials and technologies ensure that
the driver maintains control even in
extreme situations this bus has a
lightweight and yet extremely stable
frame as well as what is called a ramp
angle steering the systems function in
many ways like an electronic stability
program
ESP systems have been a standard in
Mercedes cars for twenty years the car
maker first introduced them in 1995 in
the s-class within a few years the
control program was optimized for use in
buses transporters and trucks that
wasn't easy considering the car makers
wide range of vehicle variants and
different axle configurations
superstructures and loads in the
meantime the lane departure warning
system has also reached the road giants
another example of the successful
transfer of safety technology from
passenger cars to utility vehicles is
the emergency brake assist in its newest
form active brake assist 3 it doesn't
merely minimize the consequences of a
collision it prevents a driver from
rear-ending another car completely
Daimler is pushing research in the area
especially hard when it comes to tour
buses where the lives of many people are
at stake and the new brake system works
not only in buses but also in heavy
trucks a crucial component of the
technology is the adaptive cruise
control which uses radar to keep the
vehicle in its lane and is also able to
recognize slow or stop vehicles on the
road ahead
serious highway accidents often involve
trucks plowing into cars slowed in
traffic jams now experts expect the
emergency brake assist to cut the rate
of rear-end collisions by heavy trucks
in half
biess it's Fenster the new assist stops
the vehicle says bennett though not yet
for pedestrians or cyclists that's next
on the company's agenda mercedes has
lots of new ideas to move forward in
this area and he expects a combination
of advances to enable self-driving
vehicles soon that will be another step
forward in truck safety he says normal
invited some Thema something my focus
aside technically and Germany Mercedes
recently received permission to test
self-driving trucks on public roads
vehicles like the Mercedes future truck
2025 bring together the latest results
of assistance system development the
goal is not merely to make things easier
for the driver but also to increase
safety for everyone
on the road